Shannon was it your goal to become a
studio executive in the beginning of my
career I was a development and current
programming executive on the television
side so once I left and I went off to do
Broadway National tours and I was doing
dance companies and all this other stuff
that has absolutely nothing to do with
writing when I came back to Hollywood it
was my intention to get back into
development whether that was at a
network or a studio or at a smaller
production company I was pretty open but
I realized that I liked to work in the
area where you take people from idea to
production and so I probably would have
stayed in development but it would have
necessarily been at a network or Studio
or a production company just wherever I
felt like I would be able to come in and
actually be seen and used as a person
with all of the knowledge that I have to
offer which can be hard right when you
go on any job you want to make sure that
you're going to be able to come and be
able to bring something to the table so
I was looking forward to being able to
do that and obviously it didn't go that
way that's how I ended up back into the
kind of Scripps consultant area
how did you become a studio executive so
back in the day there used to be a
program called the entertainment
Associates program at NBC Universal so a
lot of people know about Fellowship
programs for screenwriters right but
they're also used to be programs for
people who are interested in being
Executives now there are a few more that
are coming up uh Lena wake's company
Hillman grad has one diverse
representation has one but back then the
entertainment Associates program at NBC
Universal was one of the larger ones for
television and so there was an
application process and I don't know how
many people they would choose each cycle
but my cycle they chose five people I
happen to be the only one who was coming
from outside of California because I was
in graduate school when I applied I was
in film school at the time so of the
five people that were chosen two of us
weren't already working at NBC Universal
and I was the only one who came from out
of state but that program was basically
to help you to jump from the assistant
desk into an executive role because it's
very hard to make that transition simply
by sheer numbers there aren't as many
executive positions as there are
assistant positions and so if you can
imagine everyone on the same floor let's
say there are three Executives but five
assistants not everybody's going to be
able to get that one uh executive
position when it opens up so this
program was to help you to get the
skills that were necessary and help you
to kind of jump past that assistant desk
and become an executive and so I was
able to come in and be a an executive at
the Sci-Fi channel and basically learn
the whole business and learn the whole
craft while I was there we always see it
in our comments you know Hollywood is
all based on nepotism who you know did
you know anyone to get into the program
no I didn't and I think that was a good
thing and a bad thing right because it
proves that not everyone's path is the
same right so again most of the people
who got in the program were already
people who worked at NBC Universal so
that means they already had an upper
hand on all of the other applicants in
the program right because I was in in
film school at Florida State University
which means I was in the State of
Florida I didn't know anything about
this program I did not know how coveted
it was I didn't even know what
development meant right I can be honest
about that something about film school
is that most film schools teach you the
creative side they don't teach you the
business side so even though I was in
film school for two whole years I didn't
come out understanding what development
was or understanding what current
programming meant or anything about the
business side of it let alone the TV
business side of it because again most
film school programs are going to teach
you about features right because they're
really building writers writer directors
more than they're building all of the
other pieces of the puzzle so
um so yes it is true that it's mostly
about who you know in this particular
situation it was about my skill that's
all it could be because I didn't know
you know I didn't know anybody I had
interned before so I had already lived
in Los Angeles before I had already
interned at a lot of places I had
already been on several sets because I
wanted to kind of learn the ropes of how
to do everything in the business
um but I think I must have had an
awesome application and my application
um other than me being able to talk
about myself I don't really remember
much about the application but we had to
do coverage I didn't even know what
coverage was but I had a natural knack
for storytelling and obviously I had
been in a screenwriting program for two
years and all we did was sit around and
get notes to each other right and as
I've told you guys before it was there
that one of my instructors said well why
are you so good at helping other people
with their stuff and so that's what made
me seek information on are there people
out there who just help other people
write and I think that's how I got to
the word development which I think is
how it got me to the entertainment
Associates program and that's how I was
able to apply and so the program
um so it had the the rounds of
applications we had to do coverage and
then we had maybe we had a phone
interview I don't remember but then they
also flew me in I was the only person
who's coming from out so I don't know if
other people who got to that point also
got flown in but we got flown in we had
to meet with several different
departments so I met with people in
diversity I met with people in TV I met
with people in um in film I met with
people all over the lot and just me
being me I just remember being very
honest when they would ask me questions
about well what are you watching and why
and why do you like this and why don't
you like that and so I remember sitting
in one particular office and I'm at NBC
Universal and they were asking me about
the things that I was watching and
liking and two of those things happened
to be NBC shows and they wanted to know
well why are you saying these things
about the shows and I don't know if
other people would have been backed up
and tried to find something positive to
say you know what I mean but for me it
was like well here are the reasons and
so one of them was Friday Night Lights
which I think is one of the best TV
shows to ever be made however as a Texas
girl right who grew up with Family Guy
football even though I could care less
about football what I understood was you
have Friday night it's coming on at a
Friday night guess where everybody in
Texas is at their own football games so
it seems to me that you've set this show
up for failure that's basically you know
what I said to them and then another
show uh that that was out on at the time
was Heroes I really loved Heroes I
actually did a speck of Heroes and
that's what got me into the final round
of the Warner Brothers uh writing
fellowship at that time and I said you
know season one was awesome but in
season two you broke all of the rules
and therefore now we're a little bit
lost about what this show really is and
I said that to them not even considering
myself you know giving a critique or
giving notes or anything like that
that's just how I felt about it
naturally and I'm just gonna say maybe
that's the thing that got me in the
program you know what I mean because
they could see that I could explain to
them what the issue was and how I felt
like you could fix that issue so even
though nepotism in the way of who you
know not necessarily who you're related
to may have gotten some of the people in
the program I know for me it was pure
applique education thousands of people
applied and I happened to be picked as
one of the five people to do it what was
your day-to-day job as a creative
executive so here's the full
transparency of it I did not have any
idea right so I walked into this program
thinking it was going to be a program
that taught me how to be a creative
executive what I didn't understand
already and it's probably because I was
coming from the outside in which is why
I said earlier about the um the good and
the bad of it right so the good of it is
it's possible you can come from the
outside and come in the bad of it is I
don't have any information because I've
been on the outside right so I don't
know what a development executive does I
applied for this because I thought it
would be a program and I like to learn
in a classroom setting but that's not
what this was it was a job right so here
I am sitting at my desk
what am I supposed to be doing the other
people who were already in the industry
who are already assistants and
coordinators knew what they should jump
in to do because they had already been
covering the desk of Executives they had
already been seeing and being been
exposed to what Executives did I had no
exposure I had no nothing I thought I'm
going to get a desk and people are going
to give me screenplays and I'm going to
tell them what's good bad what needs to
be worked on that's what I thought the
job was it was not the job was it part
of it sure but a very very tiny part of
it so I ended up having a slower
learning curve than the rest of the
people in my cohort they were able to
get in and go meanwhile I sat around a
lot waiting on someone to tell me what
am I supposed to be doing I didn't even
know what questions to be asking and
that can be very discouraging to a
person and I'm someone who's always on
top of it I'm very confident I know what
I'm doing Etc so it was very
discouraging to me because I felt like
failure or I felt like I had been set up
to fail even though I'm sure that's not
that wasn't anyone's intention so once I
finally realized what I should be doing
my day-to-day could be taking meetings
with people as an executive it's your
job to kind of be a mental Rolodex of
Hollywood you should know the managers
you should know the agents you should
know the directors you should know the
writers you should know the up and
coming writers because if you're in a
room and someone says hey we need it's
your job to go I know a few people let
me contact them let me get their um
their samples let me figure out how to
pull them into the conversation right so
a lot of that was that and so since I
was new to the game and had come from
the outside I needed to start my my
Rolodex so I had to figure out how to
reach out to people right and be able to
uh contact them just so that we can
start a relationship and so that's why
people may hear general meeting often
because some of that that basically just
means let's just get on the phone or
let's just have a a an in-person visit
so that we can just get to know each
other so I can know what kind of writer
you are you can know a little bit about
me I can add you to my mental Rolodex it
doesn't mean you came in for a job right
just means you came in so that we can
have a conversation and kind of get to
know each other it's like a date all
right it doesn't mean we're going to be
boyfriend and girlfriend at the end but
it does mean that we got to know each
other a little better so I could be
doing that I could be taking pitches
right so that means people who think
that our brand is for their project
would come in and Pitch it to us and
we'd be able to listen to it ask
questions whatever it is we have and
then it would be our job as the uh more
Junior Executives to go in and then
pitch to our EVP about what we just saw
and if we think that it's something that
we should have here at our um on our
Network and at the network that I was at
which is sci-fi we had unscripted and
scripted and we had development and
current all happening in one place and
so for everyone who doesn't know the
difference right so scripted is going to
be your TV shows like um friends right
where it's actually scripted you have
writers who have been brought on a
writing staff to write the screenplays
whereas unscripted is what we kind of
know as reality TV some of it can be
docu-series some of it can be a little
dramatic so it might have a tiny piece
of scripted to it but it doesn't mean
that they're writing screenplays right
and then development means we are
developing the project to be on air so
this is this is the person who if you're
a new screenwriter or even if you're not
a new screenwriter but you have a
project and you want someone to buy it
you're going to pitch it to the
development people right those are the
people who are going to help you to get
it to the stage of production then your
current programming people are the
people who then take the baby after you
get it to production and take it on for
the rest of its life so however long
it's going to stay on television it
stays in the current uh programming
Department
so that would mean that features don't
have a current programming Department
because features are not on television
right so since I was in TV we were doing
all of the above and in my position I
got to kind of move around and do all of
the above so whether we were taking
pitches for a scripted or taking
pictures for um unscripted or I was
looking at the scripts coming in from
the writing staffs for the current shows
so at that time let's say um it was
Stargate Universe right so every single
script that was going to go on the air
had to come to the executives first for
our round of notes before it was going
to get approved to be able to go into
production then once it got into
production they would send us dailies
which is basically what they've recorded
the whole day what they've shot that
whole day I would also go through those
dailies then they would send us the um
the drafts of uh of each of the episodes
right and so now I'm going through and I
am kind of like an editor right but
obviously not doing the editing because
there's a post-production team but now
I'm going through and I'm Mark talking
at you know at five minutes in you know
here's a note at seven minutes in here's
a note Etc so that they can kind of go
back to make sure that it's going to fit
um what the executives are wanting it to
fit
um we would also this was a shocker for
me we were also in charge of marketing
right and I'm thinking I don't have a
marketing degree you know that's not my
job so I'm thinking the marketing
department is going to come in here and
Pitch to us what they think we should do
with this show and we're gonna go yes
that's it or no that's not it that
wasn't the case we as the executives who
were more intimate with the project
would pitch to the marketing people and
then the marketing people would take it
and execute it that was new for me so
that was a learning curve it was helpful
though because now I know how to Market
my own business right
um same thing with branding casting
wardrobe everything and executive
literally does every piece of the public
puzzle or has their hand in every part
of the process and so even though I I
got into it for the script part right
which again I did I had to read a lot of
screenplays just to
um you know when people submit their
screenplays and do a little coverage to
be able to say okay this is some this is
a writer that maybe we can work with
later or this is an idea that maybe we
can work with them to actually develop
or we're not going to do either the
above it's not for us or the writer is
just not at the level that we want to
work with now so I did a lot of that
sometimes I had to read just to read so
that I can get to know what writers were
out there what new writers were coming
um so sure reading and giving notes was
a part of the process but because I
worked in development and current a lot
of it was some of that stuff that you
would never even consider a an executive
has their hand in and so it was a big
learning curve for me so what I enjoyed
about it is that day to day could be
different right day to day
you don't know what you're going to be
doing that day because maybe you have a
big pitch meeting coming in that day
maybe you are going to end up going to
set that day the executives are the most
senior people on a set because they're
the money people right so even though
the executive producer is at the top of
their list and the directors at the top
of that list when the executive is there
that's the person who's representing the
larger brand so sometimes I would fly to
whatever state we were filming in to be
able to be the executive presence and
one of the decisions I had to make one
day which is a very very small decision
but it matters is uh we were on set
shooting a pilot and one of our
characters was a police woman but she
was a detective and so we went back and
forth about how she should wear her hair
because she's still a woman right so
people were considered you know were
concerned about is she still going to be
sexy but can we still take her seriously
etc etc well what color should her hair
be right so now we're on set and we
can't decide if she should have earrings
or what kind of earrings she should have
right and at the end of the day there's
not a decision that can be made without
the studio I'm about the studio or the
network signing off on it and so because
I was the executive there on set thank
goodness I was a woman as well that when
it came down to that earring question I
was able to make a decision not only
based on what I know the network wants
but also what's going to make this woman
look like she's the type of woman to
wear this type of earring with this type
of outfit to go on the job that she's
about to go on so this the thing that we
weren't considering at the time which is
just the fact that I'm a woman was the
thing that made me the best the best
person to be on set that day because I
was able to choose an earring so it's
that kind of stuff that people don't
really talk about when it comes to being
an executive that you don't realize the
things that they're making decisions
about how many emails were there back
and forth or calls about these earrings
oh my gosh I couldn't even tell you
especially because I was in a different
country in a different time zone and I
needed to be able to sign off on these
earrings so I'm on set taking pictures
of the earrings I'm emailing the
earrings I'm you know uh I'm calling
about them him and eventually I got a
response because for executives this is
something other also people don't really
know they're on call
they don't get vacation time you know
they can go on vacation but their phones
have to stay on if there are meetings
happening they still have to be in their
meetings because if people are on set
and questions need to be answered they
have to be answered if your phone rings
at two in the morning because someone's
on set in another time zone and it's 6
a.m their time and they're trying to get
some things done you have to answer your
phone so I knew I would get a response
at some point but it's just that I'm
only one of the other hundreds of emails
that they're getting right now and now
we're on set where time is money and we
can't keep shooting until we choose
earrings because now you have to think
of continuity well does she have
earrings in the last scene and what
earrings did she have then blah blah
blah so now we're all just sitting
around waiting
well I've chosen the earrings that this
is the one that we're gonna go with let
me just make sure that I get the you
know the sign off on it you know but
it's just it's crazy because it's like
their earrings but you know as women we
understand an earring can their
statements you know they say a lot about
about a woman and since it's a pilot and
we're trying to sell her as someone that
we want you to root for and for you to
like and care about her earrings
mattered so what did we choose what you
know I believe we chose it was a stud I
just don't remember if it was a pearl or
if it was you know something gold or
silver or whatever it was but it was a
stud because she wore a lot of collared
shirts and also we understand dangling
earrings make a statement and she wasn't
that kind of a woman you know even in
her regular dress she probably wasn't
going to put on dangly earrings
um but she definitely needed earrings so
the question of no earrings studs or
dangle it was like well we know it's not
a dangle
but it's gonna have to be a stud because
having no earrings just took her
femininity away which is really which is
really weird but because she's a
detective she's dressed just like all of
the men are right she's got on her
pantsuit she's got her collared um her
college shirt and she has her hair I
believe it was in like a short kind of
messy bun at the you know at the back
and so now we're just getting a plain
face she doesn't have a lot of makeup
right and it's like well we got to have
the one thing that makes her pop you
know to make her her look different from
everybody else and so yeah I don't
remember what color it was but we chose
a stud